and minim wrists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists and this is episode 124
I feel like it's interesting we don't do
interviews on this podcast but
occasionally we'll bring some friends on
to talk about and answers for questions
from our listeners right and Rob I don't
think we shared this with you last time
but a long long time ago like three
years ago we were your very first
podcast guess all the Rob cast yeah yeah
and then you were at our live event in
LA last year and so you were technically
our first guest on the minimalist
podcast and here's another first
you are the first repeat guest on on the
podcast humble get sense then and here's
another first this is the first time
we've had two guests on the podcast
ladies and gentleman we're here today
with Rob Bell and Andrew Morgan we're
here to talk about what we're gonna
answer some questions we can talk about
religion we could talk about
spirituality we can talk about the
nature of the universe and we could talk
about their new film it's called
The Heretic and I was fortunate enough
Ryan was gone in Seattle this past week
with our documentary showing some folks
up there but I got to go to the premiere
and I saw the film and I'll tell you
it's if you put Rob Bell on a stage with
a microphone he can talk right but we've
been this one has to day events and
he'll just he'll just maunder on in a
very articulate way for nine and a half
hours with appropriate breaks in between
the eat tacos and it's the first time
I've ever seen you speechless so after
that so there's this new film it's
called The Heretic and and ruuuu
directed the documentary and Rob you
hadn't it's about Rob's sort of journey
and this sort of transition into a new
life and it was the first time you saw
it Rob and you got up on stage and I'm
like what's going on there's a
malfunction Rob must be resetting so for
those of you who are uninformed
if we want to make it if we want to give
some backstory here so so Rob used to
you founded a megachurch for lack of a
better term a large Church in Grand
Rapids Michigan once upon a time and
then a few years ago back in 2011 you
wrote a book called Love Wins and which
I thought you know the there was this
trailer for the for the book about it
questioning whether or not Gandhi went
to hell and it seemed rather anodyne to
me but it's sort of quite a bit of
controversy and I think mostly amongst
people who probably didn't read the book
and then and then I feels like you you
you moved in this other direction and so
I think today we can talk a little bit
about maybe changing directions we got
some questions about that people
struggling with with some stuff there
but Andrew if if you you you described
Rob that night on stage right you were
doing a Q&A after the after the event
you described him let me see here as the
least cynical person that you've ever
met and I thought that was like that
that was the the the perfect description
just knowing Rob and Rob you've actually
written them as soon as you said that
I'm like I know Rob has written about
cynicism somewhere I've got to figure
out what what he said about cynicism at
one point time so a couple books ago a
book called how to be here this is what
what you wrote Rob about about cynicism
you said cynicism says there is there's
nothing new to make here often cynicism
presents itself as a wisdom but it
usually comes from a wound cynicism
holds things at a distance analyzing and
mocking and noting all the possibilities
for failure pain calls us cynics to
critique and ridicule because there
aren't any risks in doing that if you
hold something at a distance and make
fun of it then it can't hurt you and I
think this new film sort of about that
in a way and it embraced this term
heretic why'd you decide to name the
film the heretic
well I think for a lot of people there's
a feeling of being alone if they grew up
in any kind of tradition tribe group
system that sort of gave them a way to
understand the world that was smaller
than their lived experience turned out
to be so a lot of people whether it's
religion or politics or anything really
a lot of people were born into some kind
of code you know some kind of system
where it was like here's the way we see
this this this this and this and a lot
of times for a lot of us we grew out of
that we grew away from that we we
started having our own experiences and
we were made to feel crazy if we
questions that you know I mean I think
that's true for anyone in any
environment so I think one things that's
inspiring about Rob's work and and his
life that I wanted to really make note
of for people was that that is not it
really is not crazy you're not alone
you're not the first if you are having
experiences that are causing you to
question to challenge to push back on
any sort of status quo and then aside
from that it's just a ridiculous term
that I think's funny and ill-fitting for
Rob so it's like let's go there first
you know before anyone else does well
and but although other people had gone
there but but not not from your
perspective but from from a perspective
of trying to to tear someone down right
and and Rob I could tell on stage it was
the first time I'd also seen you
uncomfortable you were still like sort
of sitting and and musing over the the
title of of the film can you talk about
that well the film was Andrews idea yeah
came to Kristin and I my wife and he was
like I would I want to follow you around
and film what you do but I don't know
what the film would be so I just he's
like I just want to capture it and see
if something emerges so you'll have no
creative control no approval no editing
it's I mean that that was all very clear
and to me that's the only way to do it
is if you're gonna go in and go the
whole way like if you're going
to do it then takes I really respect
Andrews work as a person and as as a
filmmaker so then just turn just okay so
I meant so he started he started he
would film things and I don't know maybe
a year in I remember I would say things
like he's still making that film I mean
so what you saw is I hadn't seen
anything so I came to the premiere and
watched it with everybody else like
Kristen and I and the kids just said
whatever the third row and I watched it
I was watching it for the first time
what your kids say because it's as
beautiful like time capsule of there's
certainly some struggle and some issues
and I mean it starts off with with sort
of the the struggle and and using some
clips from some some people who let's
just say disagree with rob it was
actually the strangest thing than me I
remember my partner Rebecca and I went
to go see you in Spokane we were living
in Missoula yeah everything is spiritual
to her yeah yeah and we went to go see
you there and there were people out
front with megaphones and I'm like what
the hell are they doing here like who
else is here that there why are they
protesting someone megaphones in light
whatever the modern equivalent of a
soapbox is and I think it's actually
still a soapbox and they're like holding
up signs and who are they here for
because I'm here to see Rob Bell talk
about everything is spiritual like love
and grace and peacemaking and
non-violence yeah and they're like I'm
too angry for that stuff it's funny yeah
so I I genuinely when the film was over
it was it was overwhelming yeah yeah so
it was not the best time so I was like
sort of wow that was actually like five
minutes into the movie I leaned over
cursor and I was like I think this is
really good it's just a very surreal
feeling it's very surreal yeah how did
your kids react to it oh they're so cool
they they they really liked it yeah yeah
yeah they are
they just I don't know they were just
boring cool they just sort of they just
sort of keep even keel but yeah they
liked it all right well I think we we
have some questions here today if we can
go ahead and dive in and I think would
be some good jump off points for us to
talk about everything that we're going
to talk about today our first question
is from Claudia in Italy what is the
minimalist take on religion like is it a
simple religion that you follow or yeah
that that is really my question like
what is your take on religion do you
think pointless or does it really align
with the values that you have that would
be my question so thank you Ryan what is
a minimalist take on religion I think
it's hard for you and I to agree on
religion or spirituality I mean that
question is almost like asking you know
what is the Christian take on religion
or what is the Muslim take on religion
human take on gravity oh yeah yeah
what's your opinion on gravity I have a
theory no man I you know there are two
things we don't talk about on this show
and that's religion in politics because
Josh and I differ so much in it but I
was I was telling Rob before the show
here how this is like I really kind of
like using this show as an excuse to
kind of talk a little bit about religion
because you know you and I Josh we do
have two completely different beliefs
but what what I really think that people
can take away from our beliefs is that
even though we do have different beliefs
we solve a very awesome friendship we
have a very awesome business we are able
to you know talk to and bring a crowd of
people who are Christians Jewish atheist
Muslim like whatever it is it's it's a
very diverse crowd and and I think I
think maybe we could talk about it a
little bit I like what you said earlier
Rob when I brought up religion you said
no no let's not talk about religion
you said what what did you say let's
talk about well what is the nature of
reality what kind of world are we living
in so you can say that you have very
different beliefs but if I watch you
closely over the past couple of years
you all actually have very very similar
beliefs hmm that many people when they
say beliefs what they're talking about
is intellectual furniture how is your
cognitive hardware arranged which is
just intellectual assent what do you in
your rational capacities agree with or
disagree with yeah but there's actually
the place that you live from there's
actually a much deeper seat of the beam
the Greeks prefer to thus plankton which
is like the the bowels the seed of the
guts which is the place from which you
actually live and the two of you
actually if you if you spent hundreds
and hundreds of days on the road
together and you've built a business and
you spend hours together there's great
mutual love and trust and respect
between you then how you actually live
as your beliefs are actually closely
aligned yeah I think I think certainly
our values are aligned I think we're
maybe using the terms differently
whether its beliefs or values Ryan and I
have similar values I think that's why
it works like maybe we don't even use
the word beliefs here we have different
personalities for sure you know lions
the extreme extrovert I'm an introvert
and you know we have different sort of
political bullies we voted for two
different people in the last election
there were more than two people to vote
for but it's often the case that when
people are talking about beliefs
oftentimes
underneath whatever those surface
categories and labels are there is great
agreement and bonds and convictions that
are very very similar yeah so that's why
I always I always want to poke that
bubble with people with like wait wait
wait what are you talking about because
underneath the surface lots of people
that would appear to be different are
actually much closer close alliance so
the surface can be manufactured by
absolutely geography or by the the
community that you were you raised in
edia religion yeah authority figures etc
social media well no I was just gonna
say like when I read this question I was
think
about I'm singing about like how I grew
up
viewing religion so I was raised
Jehovah's Witness as I talked about with
you on my yeah my last podcast on your
podcast my first on your first podcast
and what's to me like when I think about
how I was raised as a Jehovah's Witness
here here's the narrative it is you Ryan
Nicodemus you're imperfect Jesus died
for your sins in order for you to be
saved you have to you have to follow
these rules you have to get baptized in
Jesus's name so then that way he can
forgive you for your sins and that's
that is that's the main narrative there
there was nothing in that I was taught
growing up with things like the
environment right for things like
finances I mean there was a time when
Jehovah's Witnesses they were it was in
the early 80s like late seventies they
were predicting the end of the world and
these these sheep were and I'm not using
that pejoratively I'm justice people who
were you know they're they are doing
what they feel is right they're going
out and they they literally just got
these huge loans and like just
accumulated all this debt because they
were like oh the end of the world is
coming
yeah in fact the people within your
tribe growing up I mean absolutely this
is this is I mean I think this is
tantamount to child abuse to a certain
extent you were told you you don't worry
about college because you're never going
on again 18 years old when I was 25
years think how that sets a child oh
yeah I went to my boss at 25 and I was
like hey our company pays for schooling
I want to go to college like can you
help me out and she was like she looked
at me like no one ever sat down with you
and taught you how to like approach at
college I'm like no I have no idea what
to do and it's in it is because of that
but but where I'm going with this is you
know the thing that really frustrates me
about that upbringing is that
let me unpack this the statement I got a
prophecy because it's gonna sound really
bad but this this this thing of pray to
God and rely on God for everything that
to me used to be my saving grace like to
me that was like that that that thought
of God will take care of it I don't need
to worry about it I love God God loves
me and I know because of that that I
could pretty much judge anyone I want to
judge I can project any you know anger
that I have towards these people that
I'm judging and God's got my back the
other thing too is that it absolved me
from any responsibility for things like
the environment meaning my my thought
was I don't worry about the environment
cuz Jesus he's gonna come back he's
gonna wave his magic hands and he's
gonna make everything better so why
would I care about the environment and
to me well there's literally got it
written down here uh revelation 11:18
where it talks about God ruining
destroying the people who are ruining
the earth and and that in that
description as the only reason I know
that scripture is because of being a
drove as witness because they do they do
such a good job of using the Bible but I
guess there are things like that that
stand out to me that really started to
make me question my where I was putting
all of my beliefs and I and I guess
where I stand on I would be interested
to see what you think about this where I
stand now or I guess where I or it kind
of it's not even where I stand it's
where I it's where I like I'm kind of
settled right now but I'm totally open
to changing this but I feel like there
are times in my life this morning I'm
driving to work and I'm like I'm praying
like I really want this to be an awesome
podcast like help me help me to please
make this an awesome podcast if you're
up there and you're listening help me to
make this an awesome podcast there are
other times in my life where I feel like
I need to take an atheist point of view
because I feel like putting everything
on God and not trying to figure out
something myself first it's kind of lazy
it's kind of mature
childish yes so it does now there are so
many times in life where I get to a
point where it yeah I try and can't do
it and then and then yeah I've got a
look somewhere else
um it's it's I'm not trying to say that
I am an atheist in fact I am I would say
I'm a believer and it's because of your
book
Love Wins that even made it possible for
me to have this belief because this is
such a crazy I mean me saying this out
loud it sounds really radical and weird
and I don't know if there's anyone else
out there who like agrees with me on
this but it doesn't matter because this
is it does come from a very loving spot
it does come from me being very genuine
yeah yeah and yeah I'm happy to share it
even though it sounds nuts am I crazy
what do you think no thank you first off
I think you speak for millions of people
thank you I'm so sorry you had that it's
as if the point is that we would wake up
and grow up we would grow up in our
awareness of who we are and what we're
doing here that we would wake up and see
our infinite connections with ourselves
with each other with the earth with the
entire cosmos and what you were
describing is a a giant religious
machine that was impotent when it comes
to the transformation of the human heart
mmm
it gave you rules customs rituals fears
interpretations of Revelation 11 yeah
but what it seemed to fall completely
short in is actually helping transform
your heart mmm help you be more Ryan
yeah is the only interesting thing
Camelia's the UM the most true full Ryan
is what the world needs the most of so
even going back to when people start
twitching about religion I meetly say
what in your life has no other purpose
than to help grow you up wake you up and
transform your heart because I don't
think the business world is that I don't
think academics I don't know if
Entertainment has that and historically
what happened is lots of people
tossed out primitive barbaric awful end
of the world sort of religion which they
should have but the processes they threw
out an entire dimension of life which
historically its point was to help
transform you helped shape you and grow
you there's a scene in the film in The
Heretic with with with Pete Holmes and
he's talking about like it's it's pretty
funny money metaphor and all but true
but he's basically talking about getting
rid of the Ottoman that you didn't want
in your house that's not the interesting
thing the interesting thing is is sort
of sitting there with that empty space
and figuring out what you're going to
fill it with and I think what you're
talking about is is jettison the the the
not useful or damaging side of what
we've been given but then what do we do
then what do we fill it with that we
just have this void whether you call
that a spiritual void or or just a life
void in general who's teaching us how to
live a meaningful life now right right
and you think about we're at an
emergency level with the environment
yeah so we need millions and millions
and millions of people to wake up and
grow an awareness to our endless
connections with the soil and that will
require an opening at a deep spiritual
level it may have economic dimensions
it'll have like hey there is no planet B
I mean there's like a fear terror you
can show all the movies you want but at
some deep level that is a spiritual
question that lurks underneath
everything and to deny that dimension of
it you'll never actually get at the
thing you have to tap into a deep sense
of stewardship and responsibility that
comes and those are all spiritual
matters and in the modern world a lot of
times like TED talks
don't know what to do is spirit because
it can't be proven on a spreadsheet it
can't be tested in a lab but spirit that
which is inaccessible through the five
senses and yet is more real than that
which you can hold in your hand
is the giant for many people it's been
the elephant
the room well we can't talk about
spiritual things well you're going to
have to at some point eventually but
that's like also the great opportunity
that we're living in that's what's so
inspiring about being alive right now
it's like we've spent the last decade or
two decades basically deconstructing a
lot of our institutional systems or
institutional beliefs so that's not just
religion that's you know think about our
belief in any kind of institution it's
just declined declined declined like
it's also we're living in a world that
was built half a century ago in a lot of
ways like we're still playing out the
end of a story that was started and we
know we need to transition to a new one
but we don't know how to get there so to
your point I think like there's millions
of people who are in that place with
religion or with anything where you're
like okay that stuff didn't work you
know to your point Ryan like that right
that crazy [ __ ] didn't work at all right
a lot of damage but but what's left in
that void when there's no no together
thinking when there's no ability to look
beyond as rose as the five senses and
figure out like what is happening like
never wake up and you're just kind of
like really like does this mean anything
or doesn't mean nothing yeah and if it's
possible that it means something then
maybe we need to start figuring out what
it looks like to tell a story that leads
us where we want to go and not just into
these dead ends you know and at that
like what you're describing Josh it's
like we are in that transition we are
literally in a turning point in human
history and you can feel it absolutely
absolutely and think about your path you
grew up in this narrow bonkers to use a
technical theological term I'm not
oscar's this is not offense to any
Java's witnesses nothing out there it's
nothing but love but you described
something that had some damaging effects
sure but then you turned around and
you've given these big vibrant energies
of yours I mean I went to that when I
went to that your event in LA it was
like a big living room was all of these
people coming together in the name of
human community and solidarity to ask
questions and talk about meaningful
lives yeah so so you have in many ways
it's like you're writing or wrong well
you know it's funny man is I residue of
as witness you know my conversion rate
was robbed you went door to door every
door every weekend
isn't winter in this fascinating and now
you're going venue to venue except we're
not try to convert anyone right alright
I think we're trying to share a recipe
and I think I think that's what what's
different now yes where it's not like
you must live the same way I live it's
hey here's a template that's worked from
your recipe has worked for me I don't
hope you use the same recipe in fact I
think it's gonna be difficult for
YouTube but maybe there's a few
ingredients in that recipe you can
tweeze out you can apply to your own
life yeah you can you know you can add
your own ingredients for taste and then
and you have your own recipe for more
mini fillet because my life life looks
different from his from yours from yours
and and the the reason that I think it
resonates is one of the things that you
guys were talking about with the film is
it's quite often about asking questions
more so than it is giving answers right
you said Ryan grew up with essentially
an instruction manual on how he's
supposed to live and instead of us
giving people and we're not prescriptive
in that way it's it's saying hey what
are the questions how my life be better
with less is is much more meaningful
than here are the 30 items you're
supposed to own in your collection of
whatever to be happy way it's it's the
it's the why to behind what a living a
meaningful life I think that's what we
do a really good job of but going back
to my conversion rate so let me say it
another way I didn't save one one life
when I was one of Joe's witnesses now my
conversion rate is still zero
but I can't tell you how many people
have come up to me in line they're like
dude you don't know me I feel like
you're my best friend and you saved my
life
and if it was just one person who told
me that it would make it all worth it
but that I mean literally that is the
reason why I continue to do it and I'll
tell you man I have my two biggest fears
of doing this my two biggest fears the
first one is is that people start to
think that Josh and I are like Jesus
Christ or something like that really
freaks me out
the second fear is is that being raised
as one of Java's witnesses I was told
that if you're not a Java's witness
while you're being influenced by Satan
the devil so like I I have to look in
the mirror and be like dude are you the
devil like are you being influenced by
Satan like I really have to face that
and I'll tell you because
of the events because of what you
witnessed there's no way I can be doing
wrong and if I am then then then I guess
I disagree with whoever thinks this is
what I'm doing is wrong you know yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely
for sure so for me I guess when it comes
to minimalist religion I guess there
isn't there isn't one religion that Josh
or I will ever say hey this is the one
religion that that you should that you
should have or these are the beliefs
that you should have I think for me it's
about what what is it that my my heart
and my mind tell me our good morals like
what is it that makes me feel guilty
because I hate feeling guilty
so whatever it makes me feel guilty I
don't do that and whenever it makes me
feel like I am being a genuine person
and adding a lot of value to other
people's lives then I do that so for
anyone out there who's you know confused
on religion I would say start there and
then maybe start to pick and choose what
tribes you want to maybe be involved
with if there's a tribe at all that you
want to be involved with and your I feel
like the this making this film was a bit
of a search for you or maybe the
beginning and then the process of a
search during the qat the other night
you were talking about how it was in one
way sort of your most personal film even
though it's about Rob but it was almost
like you were searching you know by
proxy right and you had this proxy of of
change of asking different questions
questions that maybe you weren't used to
can you talk a little bit about that
that search for you because it sounds to
me like that's what Claudia is asking
here she's she's also searching yeah for
sure I mean I think that was that was
think for me when I met Rob I had I had
come from a background that was very
conservative very evangelical I'd grown
away from a lot of that and so I think
when I met Rob I was really interested
in the things he was talking about
because it it was fascinating to me just
on like a personal level you know like
it was a it was a totally different way
to approach some of these ideas and that
was super super super interesting to me
and then also I think I think for me
like I I'm just super super interested
and this is why I really respect the
work you guys are doing I'm very
interested in the ways that the stories
that we believe and the stories that
were telling really are shaping and
defining our world and I think I had
come through a period I had told some
stories before this I had done some work
that was much more just on the general
like journalistic awareness like there
are some emergencies happening on planet
earth and if we can just get more people
to know about them then we'll inevitably
create a better world and I had sort of
bumped up against the edge of that so
for me it was like I'd sort of put
religion so I kind of put that stuff
behind me I'd sort of leaned fully into
this idea of there are things happening
they're suffering they're their issues
in front of me that I can do something
about and I think what made it
interesting again was this subtle sense
of wait how does the whole thing move
forward and what is holding it back so
both on a very personal standpoint what
does it take for human beings to wake up
like we haven't figured out how to
forgive our enemies we can't seem to get
endless war and violence and out of
circulation and and so maybe there are
tools buried in some of these traditions
that could help us right now so both on
an individual basis maybe there are
tools that can help me make sense of the
life that I find myself living and then
collectively maybe if we're serious
about moving forward maybe if we're
serious about building a more just more
humane future up ahead
then we need to stop just putting
band-aids on we need to start looking at
what are the root causes and certainly
for me living in America I don't think
you can take I don't think you can
understand this country this context
this moment we're living in without
taking seriously the impact that
religion has had and you could argue for
them for the worse for the better
irrelevant to me it has a stranglehold
on our collective moral imagination and
so for me that just became really
interesting if you were if you were to
walk down the street maybe not in LA but
if you were to walk down the street
there are in as ten people that was
Noah's Ark a real event it was it a real
historical event a 60% of the people
will say yes so to me that it's to your
point of how strong of a hold religion
has well and again this isn't this isn't
for or against religion we're just
talking about what it is yeah I think
what Robert says you're asking the wrong
question well that was the other thing
happened is you know we we we started
making this film in 2015 and then 2016
rolled around and we had an election
mm-hmm and it was like we watched as all
the knobs got turned up and and it was
like religion came to the surface again
yeah again for better or worse if you if
you started noticing and I was noticing
just because I happened to be making a
film so I was watching the news and a
different way and as I listened to the
vocabulary as I listen to the examples
we use as I listen to like our
collective touchstones you know like
mm-hmm
they are rooted in these traditions and
this one tradition in particular so I
think it it instantly was like oh this
isn't ancillary this cuts to the heart
of this thing that we're doing my
favorite line in the in the heretic
about religion I think was Pete Holmes
uh he said Oh bunch of this help me help
me help me get this line right but it's
he said something along the lines of if
you really want to know like you know if
you have the right religion or not like
look at look at what you use your
religion for I know I'm like
paraphrasing this and butchering it but
it was about what does it make you do
what does it make you do does your
religion - is it divisive is it is it is
it oh that's what it was is it does your
religion exclude you or does it or does
it include everyone and to me like that
is Pete Rollins that iran's too late
Pete's yeah to me Pete um well yeah and
yeah but uh that to me like that is the
can you say that again with an Irish
accent every time I do an Irish accent
it comes across as like Eastern Europe
yeah I don't know why but
but but you know again for Claudia here
you know that's that's the question that
I asked myself like with any religion
anyone who's trying to to to because
people come to us all the time oh you
know it's so nice like they'll come up
and give us a nudge like it's so nice to
see two Christians going out and spread
spread and Jesus's message and then like
you know a few people later they're like
yes and then they'll come up and they'll
say you know to see two young men like
you going around and spreading the
teachings of Buddha is so encouraging
and and and you know any religion that
gets presented to me that's kind of how
I look at it I'm like is this a it does
this religion exclude or does it include
and and for me that is kind of I guess
one of the main identifying marks of my
beliefs I guess maybe you could have an
official statement for the minimalists
is that we are trans religious and all
that we do I love that and we're we're
we're a binary religious maybe your your
official like we are trans religious we
work to create a space where people from
every tradition or no tradition feel
welcome to pursue with us the issues of
deepest fullness and vitality so see you
Sean all you have to do is isolate a
question about religion so I have it on
like a little soundboard yes you have no
problem with these traditions to the
degree to which these traditions help
shape the kinds of people yeah
yes and I want to be clear that
minimalism is not I don't feel like
minimalism is a substitute for these
things I don't feel like I don't feel
like someone could stop being a
Christian and then you know take up this
philosophy and still feel fulfilled
I think minimalism is a tool well you
know it's sticking with the the
religious theme look at all the the
major prophets in any religion like
there is one major thing they all have
in common
and that's all living a simple life yeah
right yeah right so yeah again I don't
think I don't think minimalism is a
supplement but I certainly think it's a
tool like at all I think that's a good
transition to our next question here
from Sarah in Virginia so I am a study
middle of minimalism and simplicity as a
form of religion because I can't relate
to most religions but I believe in God
and that we are all one and connected
and find that this topic gives me
inspiration encouragement to live a
better
life do you have any recommended
resources that you've came across that
have to do with spirituality and
minimalism also my second question is
have you considered a way to have many
groups from meetups by state on your
website I've been a member of your DC
and New York City meetups but I'm moving
to rural Smith Mountain like Virginia
any suggestions on meeting like-minded
individuals in rural communities would
be helpful I'm envisioning something
similar to like a local free cycle group
thank you right
all right Josh you know of any local
meetup groups that Sarah can go to I
think we could go plant some minimalist
churches across America oh man um we we
that we do have minimalist org is what
Sarah was referring to where basically
if you go to minimalist org there's
probably in the United States is
probably a city within a couple hours of
you that will host local meetup groups
the reason why a local meetup group yeah
and the reason why Josh and I did this
was because the first tour we went on
back in 2011 people would come up to us
and they're like man this was really
awesome in so many cool people here what
other what other things can I be part of
to be around these people and how can i
how can I hang out with these people and
Josh and I are like Facebook like
OkCupid like we didn't really have a
good answer so when we went on tour in
2014 we set up these 100 meetup groups
most of them in North America but
essentially you've got people one person
specifically in each community who has
stepped up to say yeah I will facilitate
these groups there's no agenda or
anything like that it's it's people
getting together very much like what you
saw in Los Angeles just kind of a
smaller version of that she said she
said like-minded too and I'm actually
cautioned against that I don't want to
always meet we just like-minded people
right in fact I want to meet with non
like-minded people quite a bit to get me
outside of my comfort zone so may be
open-minded is a better way to sort of
talk about that right how do how do I
connect with open-minded people locally
and and she she said one things I study
minimalism as a as a form of religion
and that's why I said that was a good
trend
last question because it's certainly not
that right it is it is simply a
philosophy of simple living for us but
she mentioned that we are all connected
but then of course she's lost this sense
of connection in a way so I I don't know
what you guys thoughts are or what you
can tell Sarah here about about the the
connectedness because we're in a world
that's more connected than ever I say
that with vocal quotes here but it's
also less connected yeah we've ever been
and she asked for some resources on you
know what maybe she could look at to
help her get reconnected what like what
do you read man I know what you read Rob
what do you read in know just get bunch
of books Rob gives me Rob's books but I
think I think more than resources I
think what's interesting is I talk to a
lot of people that say the same thing
because they stopped going to church and
then they realized that you know church
had a really useful it was it was nice
because they had a meal together
or they had like you know I mean like
there was a thing like it that was an
anchor in their community and so there's
a lot of people that now have to figure
out like how do you do that you know um
I go surfing with some people there are
people that hike you know I run with
people you guys have these events you
have these groups like I think that's
what's that's what's you know at that's
one of the risks of being lost I think
and even going back to us saying about
we're figuring all the things we don't
believe in but then it's kind of like
but what are those things that still
anchor us together you had this line the
film Rob where you say we think we're
looking for solutions but really we're
looking for solidarity and I think at
the very best of religion that was what
it was designed to do it was really
designed to say we're in this thing
together yeah you know what in the film
- Rob you said embrace the unraveling oh
yeah that was wrong stew man I'm gonna
kill you no no I respect you please
forgive me for misquoting you as he says
this is your last day it'll sound so
charming
that you'll be doing with it apparently
this is my last day but but but the
unraveling is it is a process I think
that Sarah should embrace this isn't a
it's not it shouldn't be as scary it is
scary but we don't have to make it that
scary I guess so yes yeah yeah and I
would say to Sarah that it's easier to
give birth and raise the dead so what
does a gathering or tribe look like that
would that could sustain the kind of
life she wants so start it in your
living room with a meal everybody brings
a meaningful quote or paragraph or song
like keep it as just straightforward
we're having this meal everybody's
bringing something and bring some
snippet paragraph page quote that has
somehow fed you at some deeper level
yeah even call it spiritually inspired
you or something you could keep it
really and everybody I mean start there
yeah and what you're seeing is people
realizing that when they look at Andrew
said they previously looked to
institutions to organize facilitate
things and what you're seeing now is
people realizing well I could actually
do that yeah I don't need a cathedral in
order to have a group of P my to go to a
temple the whole thing is a temple so I
would ask Sara like that's the really
interesting thing about this moment is
you have people who are lonely who
realize but there are other people who
are lonely and that right there it's
like in math and the kid when they're
like wait two negatives equal a positive
what just gathering together in your
loneliness does something to negate the
loneliness so what is that gathering
that if you went to it you'd be like I
could have done this yeah what's it look
like probably involves food probably
involves a good art probably involves
some sort of shared mission is there
something locally that you could all
pitch in money to that you could serve
at it probably involves something larger
than your
so otherwise it becomes a country-club
yeah now that just gets interesting
people start asking those questions yeah
I think the contribution is often a big
part of that you had a guy named Levi
Gardner the gardener on your podcast
recently and it was so great he has this
little plot of land someone's loaning to
him in Grand Rapids and talk about
creating a community space it's it's
around growing food in this like vacant
lot and all of a sudden people are
showing up and it's bringing it's a
sense of community and and it reminded
me I was having a coffee with a mutual
friend of ours Louis house yesterday and
he he he and I were talking about about
the documentary and I remember on his
podcast he asked you robbed us-- look at
a church and you said what do you think
we're doing right now and those two
really connect to me like because if you
feel this sort of obligatory sense I
must show up I must perform this
sequence of ritual or whatever that's
different from how can I contribute and
asking these questions of how can i
connect how can I contribute what what
does this mean to be a part of something
greater than than myself
yeah well let's talk about books I was
actually interested to see what you were
gonna say about books on because she
specifically asked any recommendation
recommendations for resources about
spirituality yeah so do you have any
books that you've read that I mean
obviously like I'm not going to say
obviously but um I know that you've read
Sam Harris is waking up yeah which is a
great book on kind of like the science
behind spirituality almost right here's
here's something fascinating I think -
the biggest influences on on that side
of my life or they wanna call it
spirituality we're gonna call is Rob
Bell and st. marys yeah and it's like I
think it's weird because people often
look at them like they're two completely
different people but I think the Venn
diagram between Sam Harris and Rob Bell
is like 80 or 90% and he may be turned
off by the term spirituality and he's
trying to reclaim it which I actually
really like the fact that he's like okay
it's a it's a guide to spirituality
without religion is his book waking up
but I think you all are often talking
about similar things you're approaching
them from completely different circles
and and I've had quite a few people
mentioned I hey you guys talk about Sam
Harris sometimes in the podcast he was
in your documentary you had Rob Bell on
the podcast like it's fascinating you
have these these two different sides and
so I think no matter what the resources
are try to find the different angles
that are appealing to you and sometimes
find the angles that are a bit of a
turn-off
yeah because sometimes you realize like
once you get past the thing that the the
dogma that you had in your head once
you're able to sort of shed that that
surface layer the facade you get into a
home that is that is truly beautiful
yeah it's like the first so I've got a
couple resources written down here the
first one I've written down is Eckhart
Tolle he's the power of now and for me
like that I had to take that approach
with Eckhart Tolle because I don't I am
NOT I am NOT that woo-woo II there are a
lot of things that I disagree but but
that book was one of the best books I've
ever read when it comes to spirituality
but isn't that kind of like an old
religious mindset anyway that you can't
learn from something you don't agree
with like when did that ever begin to be
the law yeah no and I read that book 810
years ago maybe and and that is that is
when I started coming out of it that is
when I started realizing like oh if
you're gay God isn't going to kill you
but I started coming out of it Stanton I
started I started going after different
stuff but like Eckhart Tolle I love that
that the power now because it helped me
get a firmer grasp on the ego like any
time that I feel all prideful like I
because of that book like I have a tool
that I can look at that pride and say
hey Ryan it's great that you feel good
buddy but when you act out that doesn't
make other people feel good and and I
can actually look at these different
emotions that I have the spirit that I
feel are spiritual emotions I can
totally deal with because of a book like
that but yet again to the point of go
out and read stuff Sarah if you're a
Christian go read the Quran I mean it
seriously like go out and make yourself
uncomfortable and at least look at
something else it
instead of listening to what clergy has
to say or what friends and your religion
who you really respect have to say what
they say about one religion doesn't
necessarily mean that's what it is
I would I would just yeah again
encourage to go out and at least look at
something and say yes you know what
they're right that's crazy or Wow
you know maybe they're not looking at it
a certain way or or maybe you know Sarah
here sees it in a different way but yeah
certainly reading things that make me
uncomfortable helped me grow more than
anything with my with my spirituality
and you have any books that you would
recommend or like besides you know
obviously besides all of your books and
just go one at a time recognize every
one of your books I think Rumi's big red
book is really really really been huge
to me
I'm Room er um I is a twelve century
Sufi mystic and the compendium of his
works is called the big red book and it
will ya that's fairly amazing I think
Sarah might love Diana Butler bass is a
scholar who wrote a book called grounded
and essentially her premise is that for
thousands of years people had a
three-tiered view of the universe
there's a god up there raise your
prayers up send it up and that God comes
down so there's a three tiered view and
then there's the earth and then below
the earth must be some sort of place
where darker things happen right and
that prayer then was trying to get the
beam who's up there to come down here
and intervene and her argument as a
scholar is that that God died in the
Holocaust because that God did not come
down and show up so that entire
framework for thinking about
spirituality has died essentially in in
the modern mind and that you have these
new images why her book is called
grounded of the idea of the divine is
the grip and a man named Paul Tillich
talked about the ground of your being so
instead of is this religion right and
that religion wrong what is the ground
of our being and what is the nature of
is it love is it hate is it inclusion as
exclusion but she might that's a book
that site gives you this great oh that's
what's happening and that's why certain
things used to work and don't work
anymore
and then there's endless I think she
would love an Lamont's work okay like
traveling mercies there's a whole body
of work by in Lemont that's just vanish
I can't wait for this night I can't wait
for the show notes so I can go back and
read stuff shall we you put all these in
the show notes please oh I could go I
get ya there's endless now that's the I
mean to recommend I mean we don't want
to give a whole library to read but
that's that's yeah yeah all right let's
move on and we got to get these guys out
of here after our lightning round we'd
love to hear what you all have to say
though if you're at home listen to this
you have a comment or tip about religion
or or spirituality or heresy or
you know hair advice whatever it may be
including putting advice for any of our
callers today leave us a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine you can also send a voice memo
right from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists comm where our favorite
comments and tips at the end of each
episode Ryan what time is it it is time
for our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media indeed we do
we are on Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists during the
lightning round this is where Ryan and I
both do our best to answer each question
with just a short shareable less than
140 character response we call them
minimal Maxim's and hopefully Robb and
Andrew will join us and no you know
anything prepared so you can monitor on
a bit before you get your your tweetable
bit or will tweeze out a tweetable bit
for you and we also put all these middle
Maxim's in the show notes so you can
copy and share our our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like you can find
all of our our pithy quotes in one place
now over at minimal Maxim's comm Ryan
what I know it's me all right
our first question is from Mike did a
lot of pain come with the church turning
its back on you and if so have you been
able to move past it and do you accept
the title of heretic like a badge or do
you simply shake it off so this question
is mostly for you Rob how what do you
think it's I'm fascinated by the way he
decided to phrase that right the church
turning its back on you I don't know
even though the church yeah I just never
had that sort of narrow hierarchical
view of the church I always saw there
was this world of people who were all
hungry for depth we're hungry for
meaning were huggy for significance
we're hungry for a story that might
actually bring the world the healing and
hope and direction it needs so I
reclaimed I stumbled into the sermon
when the band I was in broke up I
discovered the sermon as an art form for
everybody not for religious people over
the corner but as a as the original art
form somewhere between guerrilla theater
performance art attends high school
color this is early 20s okay
somewhere between guerrilla theater
performance art a TEDTalk a revival and
recovery meeting I had this sense like
the sermon Martin Luther King I have a
dream that was a sermon yeah and so I
set out to create these spaces where
people could help wake up so that's
always what it was like so somebody over
in the corner who didn't like it it just
wasn't it was always kind of irrelevant
to be honest so I just kept going yeah
I'm gonna join it more than ever so
that's how I'd answer that is I said yes
to something and I just kept pursuing it
25 years later I'm still pursuing it I
love it
and that changes over time right I mean
so long so evolution yeah yeah yeah you
you started a church in the late 90s and
that served its purpose for a particular
yeah I did that for a while and it was
amazing and then you have to keep going
right right because if you continue to
live the same way that you live before
I'd still be playing with GI Joes it's
important to think about it for a reason
for a season and that many people have a
very static view of their life which is
this is what I do and so I guess I'd do
this till I die but if you think about
earlier agricultural settings you have
seasons if planting if harvest you have
the barrenness of winter things start
and they reach their peak and then they
fade then they're over then a new thing
starts so sometimes you need to leave
that job because it's good like that was
a chapter otherwise I could become what
was a graduation can become a divorce
you stayed too long right
so I think you have to move to more
dynamic like agricultural metaphors for
life which is this is what I'm doing
this is where the ground is fertile and
then I'll know when it's time for this
season to end the next one to start we
said something the other night that I
wrote down which is with my iPhone
started typing some stuff you said
calling is overrated curiosity is
underrated yes and and I think that's
what we're because sometimes we live
where we're constantly living in the
rearview oh remember the high-school
football game remember that job that I
had or that accomplishment that that
felt really great at the time and it's
good celebrate the accomplishment but
but when we dwell on it for too long or
here's the other side of it or we're
constantly looking toward that next
accomplishment the next goal the next
achieve in the next two Thema and then
we get there and we're more miserable
than ever and and I found that that Rob
I think the thing that you do really
well is I mean you wrote a book how to
be here and so like it's it's the it's
the work it's the create the craft the
the creation that that is the thing that
gets you up it's not the man if this
could only sell a hundred thousand more
coffees then I'll be happy yeah and I
think that's that's where we get caught
up we get so caught up on on the surface
of things the how many tweets or
retweets how many Instagram followers
whatever it is and we lose sight of like
what is actually what's important in in
the now yeah you know I think rub it
would because this question it sounds I
mean if I didn't know you and reading
this question I would think the person
being asked this question it would be
like a like bitter and resentful and I
think I think don't have time for such
things I just don't have time but you
know III guess the reason why I'm
pointing this out is because for
listeners out there like you had you
have you had you still have a choice
like you can look at it and say man
Church turned their back on me or you
can look at it and say no like I'm just
gonna go to my calling I'm not gonna sit
here and victimized or be played a
victim
I'm going to do what I need to do and
that's how you can live a meaningful
life for yourself and I think it's it's
too often where people will get caught
up and they were wronged they will they
will take that victim role because it's
easier to do that than it is to really
stand up for what you truly value right
and it's important a mantra that helps
me is and then what like if you're gonna
get a tattoo forget barbed wire or a
Chinese symbol gate and then what
so they wronged you and then what so
they fired you and then what yeah
because you otherwise you are giving
that person so much power over you that
they don't deserve so you see people
energetically and spiritually handing
others power left and right look what
she did to me and how it has shaped my
life that that person does not deserve
to have that kind of hold over your
heart and your joy so they did that yes
and then what yeah because you have
today you have the power of now what are
you going to make today that's just
fundamentally more interesting yeah it
reminds me of a guy named Jacko willing
he always says good and when something
screws up in his life and he says good
good giant former Navy SEAL but yeah he
does constant you know all you know
whatever the the project failed or the
plane the flight was canceled good like
what did I learn from this because
otherwise it's me the same thing so
there's his pithy answer Shawn for the
show notes and then what mine is is
similar to kind of what Rob was talking
about we must we must walk away to move
on right I think sometimes we're trying
to move on but we're staying in the same
place just sort of spinning around and
and wondering
we're staying tethered to where we are
and we're not walking away so I think
sometimes you have to walk away in order
to in order to move on
and it's not a bad thing in fact like
you said sometimes you have to leave the
job even though you love it yeah but my
pity answer would be you don't need
clergy to tell you you're doing a good
job at life and man my dad he doesn't
really talk to me because I live with my
partner and her and I are not married I
don't think I'll ever get married again
I just it's something that her and I are
not that's not in our future really for
me to go out of my way to get married
just so my dad would talk to me like
that would be to me that feels wrong but
I guess where I'm going with this
is even though even though my dad you
know it doesn't really give me the time
of day I cannot I cannot allow that to
prevent me from from being the Ryan
Nicodemus that I really really want to
be and there's something that you said
when we went to your event and was at
Orange County I look at a beach yeah
yeah somewhere down there or am i
repeating myself what is in the other
but you were talking about how you know
when you dedicate yourself to your craft
or when you when you dedicate yourself
to whatever it is that you're pursuing
you have to accept the consequences that
come with that and there are some heavy
consequences with a lot of things that
that some of us accept and thanks for
help me accept the consequences man I
appreciate all my pleasure there's
always a cost yeah all right our next
question is from overlook do we actually
choose our beliefs or are they a result
of an unconscious process dude that is
the Pythias answer we've ever had in the
lightning round yeah you're a human
being you are vitamix of nature and
nurture and impulse and instinct and
really well thought through intentions
and reflexive reptile brain responses to
threat assessment you're all this stuff
yeah so out of that vitamix of things
swirling around in you that's why a
practice that's why a path that's why
even the idea of a religion can be
incredibly helpful it's simply to take
all of that and give you a path so that
you your heart might actually be
transformed you might actually be able
to take part in the healing of the world
yeah he totally stole my pithy answer
mine was just your your beliefs are a
path to your values and and that that's
what well often when I talk about having
the different beliefs it's like we
ultimately end up at the same
destination and yeah I agree with that
and in fact I like the Vitamix metaphor
a lot better because you know it's all
just sort of in there right you can't
and once it's all blended yeah good luck
tweezing it out right it can't get the
blueberries out of the smoothie once
it's made man and now I just want to
prove you wrong somehow with science
did you know they figured out how to
unboiled egg I swear to God
anyway my pet the answer is this we mean
that that was your fifth the answer if
you tweet is maybe you should that's a
tweet just that did you know did you
know figured out my pet the answer would
be this we may not get to choose our
beliefs but we do get to choose how
close we hold them so what I mean by
that is there are dogmatix that I have
right now I can't get rid of like I
believe in something more I still have a
lot of the Jehovah's Witness dogmatix
and especially the morals and the I just
doing what I believe is in alignment
which is funny because I had to leave
the religion in order to do in order to
feel like I was doing something right
but they taught me to do that which is
crazy leaving was how you were true to
it exactly exactly yes
so I still have these very deep-seated
beliefs and dogmas but I don't take him
too seriously and I get to choose how
serious I take them and I get to choose
the lens ilex room and and that is it's
the most freeing feeling in the world to
be able to to do that and to say like
yeah here's what I here's what kind of
where I sit now but it might be
different next year and that's all right
there like so much humility that comes
from that that sense of like my
experience like my beliefs have been
shaped by the experiences that I've had
where I was born when I was born you
know all those things the things that
really have moved or changed something
inside of me usually have become when I
have had an experience when I've gone
somewhere when I've seen something when
I've experienced something which gives
me a ton of humility for anyone who
believes something different than me
absolutely it also gives me a ton of
humility for just how much is out there
that I've never experienced I mean like
I'm living in this one little sliver of
one little take on reality on this
planet at this time you know like Mike's
my experience is so small so like it
just always makes me want to stay in
that posture I think about because a lot
of my work is listening to people and I
I think about that posture of a student
why would we want to slam the door on
that why would we want to get done with
school or why would we want to add
there's such a there set like we value
the certainty of like the person on the
news show that has the you know but like
isn't there's so much more join so much
more like honestly like so much more
life in and realizing I'm a different
person than I was five years ago ten
years ago I'm gonna be a different
person to ten years now I'm gonna look
back at myself and be like Oh Mike you
were still doing that you're addicted to
that you still believed but like that's
freeing to be like man glad I worked
through that yes if I disagree with you
I'm gonna do it lightly yeah yeah what
you identified is and what Anders
talking about is there is what you
believe and then equally as important is
how you hold that belief mmm and a lot
of people miss that distinction that
there is the conviction and then there
is how you hold it and there is a white
knuckling of a belief which crushes the
belief and drains the life right out of
it and then there is an open palm which
is how
you hold it which means this matters
might I might even die for this and yet
I also am always as a lifelong student
open to it changing and morphing and so
you'll often notice people who they're
right but in a wrong way is because they
are holding it wrongly which is just as
important as what the belief is in the
first place
yeah eight wheats in a row several yeah
well throw them in the show so let's get
Meghan's question we've got one other
question here from Giselle how do we
keep our souls most alive now we're
going to answer this question with each
week we do a something called the
minimalist private podcast it's a
PostScript episode where we answer a
bonus question for our patreon
supporters if you want to support us
just head on over to the minimalists
comm and click donate at the top that
keeps his podcast 100% advertisement
free because well advertisements suck
you also get access to our monthly live
streams it's called ask the minimalists
anything recordings from our live events
we just put out Philly and Tampa and
Detroit and DC recently we've got some
others coming soon and we're in this new
studio space which still has the
temporary furniture and not all the
equipment but we're gonna give you a
video tour of the new studio space that
you're helping support so thank you to
all of our patreon supporters well dive
into that question in a moment but first
Ryan let's move on to our added value
portion of the show so where we each
talk about something that has added
value to our lives recently since we
have Rob and Andrew here today I think
we might as well go ahead and and and
make it Rob and Andrew centric I think
that's appropriate yeah
first thing I'll recommend is the Rob
cast for those of you who don't listen
to it's a great podcast if you're
looking for an episode to start with
we've talked about Pete Rollins recently
he didn't episode about parables and it
was so good and he has he has a new
podcast out now - he's reclaimed the
word fundamentalist and it's called the
fundamentalists but Rob had a great
conversation about parables with Pete
and you you seemed like just fascinated
you just like let him do his thing
and that's what you do with Pete Rose I
think so he's great so that's episode
183 we'll put a link to that on the show
notes as well yeah I got a recommend
true costs if
people haven't seen it that is it's the
it's the documentary that I wish we
would have done man it's it's really
good because it just dives into what
really goes into our consumption and if
you're if you haven't seen it it will it
will truly change the way you perceive
the way the world consumes there's no
doubt about it
yeah especially with respect to clothing
fashion industry it's it's a good
introduction or at least maybe a follow
up to watching The Heretic yeah two
totally different films and that's
impressive and in the end of a cell
because you didn't do you know true cost
- with Rob Bell different things also if
you have children rob has a audio book
for a book that doesn't exist called
launching rockets it's like 17
observations on on on parenting but it's
not just with Rob he brings Kristin and
so you can just fast-forward to that
part and listen to Kristin's observation
on his observations it's very Kafka
esque but it's I think it's great man
and and here's here's the fascinating
thing I found out about you Rob is you
had some really good observations about
parenting and I have a four year old now
and so I've tried to apply those to my
own life but the thing that told me that
you were a really good parent is when
you brought your son trace on - on to
the podcast and just like had him talk
about politics and the nature of the
world and I saw how man he was he's he's
a 35 year old on a 17 year old body so
just no other words that other thing
Bravo and congratulations man that's
very kind of you yeah you and Kristin
have raised at least one good kid I
don't heard the other two kids on the
podcast yet but let's move on the right
here right now is where we talk about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist just a few things here we're
starting a video version of this podcast
this summer if you want to subscribe to
that you can do so at youtube.com slash
the minimalists also my partner Rebecca
you probably know her from minimal
wellness.com she has a 23 day wellness
reset going on in
of this year and she takes on 30
students at a time and sort of helps
them reset their their diet their health
their wellness and so those those tend
to sell out pretty far in advance but if
you're interested in that it's 23 day
reset over at minimal Wellness comm if
you want all the show notes you keep
hearing let's talk about the show notes
that Sean podcast Sean here creates you
can just sign up for email lists at the
top of our website we'll never send you
spam because that stuff's gross but
we'll also send you any new writings
that we put out any new essays anything
like that Ryan you got anything else for
us finally here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners hi
Josh and Ryan this is Sienna
from Orange County California I just
have an idea for all the artists out
there with their supplies my fiance and
I had an idea while ago to start kind of
like a gym but for artists where you
have a membership and instead of having
like a cardio section in a weap section
you have a painting section or a pottery
section or something like that we don't
have the resources right now to start
one ourselves but if there's anybody out
there who has the resources and as super
into art we've always thought that would
be a really cool idea so artists didn't
have to have all their own supplies they
could just have a membership and show up
and create art and then go hi Ryan and
Josh this is Amanda from Melbourne I'm
so excited to be coming to your live
show tonight about a year ago after
listening to a few of your podcasts I
decided to start decluttering my house I
struggled getting started though as the
whole task felt too overwhelming luckily
for me I had a good friend who was in
the same situation and we agreed to join
forces for the last 12 months my friend
Sam and I spent every Friday together
alternating between her house and mind
helping each other work our way through
every cupboard shelf and storage area
some weeks have been really emotionally
stressful some have seen us covered from
head to toe in dust but we have donated
and thrown away hundreds of kilograms of
no longer needed items and have had a
lot of fun along the way
hi guys my name's Sally from Victoria
Australia I wanted to share with you an
app I heard about on Dan Harris's 10%
happier podcast ironic I know but I'm
trying to reduce the app so I have on my
phone I swear but I found this one to be
quite meaningful the apps called wee
croak and for 99 cents you get a
reminder 5 times a day at random times
that you're going to die I know this
sounds a little grim but it has truly
had a really positive impact on my
day-to-day life overall I would say I've
tried to embrace the goal of living my
life according to my values but on a
daily basis I know I can easily be
troubled and distracted by the little
things being randomly reminded
throughout the day that I'm going to die
has meant that in the moment I'm not
sweating the small stuff as much I've
noticed shifts in my behavior in small
ways I guess say getting off Twitter
more quickly when I find that I'm down
that rabbit hole I'm putting down a book
say that I'm not enjoying or even like
lighting a favorite candle just because
the no reason and not thinking that I
should save it for another day I don't
know why I would do that anyway bigger
reflections I've also noticed such as
not caring so much about what people
think I found that I am moving on more
quickly from mistakes that I've made and
most importantly to me it's really
emphasized on a daily basis the
connections that I have with the people
I love and how much I want to focus on
on those people so I found this really
valuable and I hope fellow listeners
might find this to you alright so before
we we dive out of here I just want to
say thank you real quick to rob and say
thank you drew you guys are just amazing
I'm grateful that you decide to spend
some time with us I hope folks check out
The Heretic and if they want to check
you out online then go to your socials
they can go well you're not really on
the socials you are a little bit right
yeah not so much
good for you
we check out the hair that gets on
iTunes and Amazon and Rob Rob Balcom is
the hub for all of your work and really
gratefully decided to spend some time
with us if if you're at home you listen
to this and you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm and if you leave
here with just one message we hope it's
this a lot of people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening you know we'll see you
next time